a court in belarus has handed down an
18-year prison sentence to opposition
figure sergey tekonovsky according to
state media sergey is the husband of
svetlana ticonovskaya who took over as a
presidential candidate in his place
the former video blogger had attempted
to run for president against alexander
lukashenko in the august 2020 elections
but was arrested before the vote today a
court sentenced him on charges of
organizing mass unrest in a video
message ahead of the verdict his wife
svetlana who is currently in exile in
brussels said she expected her husband
would be given a lengthy sentence and
she vowed to keep fighting for him
i will continue to defend the person i
love and who has become a leader for
millions of belarusians
i will try to do something very
difficult maybe impossible to bring
closer the moment when we will see each
other in a new belarus
so let's get straight across to a kiev
and correspondent nick connolly hi nick
what more can you tell us about this
story
well the extraordinary thing about this
case that's been at the center of
attention in belarus for months now is
that it has been going on behind closed
doors in that jail in the regionality of
gomer only about 200 km why i'm here in
ukraine's capital kiev not even the
relatives being able to really find out
what's going on there and lawyers have
been
thrown out indeed sere tiranovsky's
lawyer for most of the case was
had her legal license removed during the
case you had to change lawyers so it's
basically a very difficult situation
where very little has come out but i
think this is really important because
the regime is making clear that it is
not in any move compromise we had a
10-year sentence familiar media
calisthenics and other
prominent opposition figures so this
18-year
sentence is really an attempt to
raise the stakes maybe as some kind of
diplomatic kind of pawn maybe these
people will be their freedom will be
exchanged some kind of reduction in
sanctions by the west or in the hope
that they will eventually break under
all the pressure and you know come to
some kind of deal but prosecutors admit
some kind of responsibility and come on
state tv and you know talk about why
they were wrong to oppose alexander
luchenko so far most of these opposition
figures have been staying firm in their
rejection these charges and now this is
the consequence of that um
extraordinarily long jail terms ahead
for these people
now one way or the other this sentence
doesn't exactly come as a surprise uh
what does it mean for tikanovskaya and
the belarusian opposition as a whole
well i think for celentia konovska this
was unlikely a surprise i think they
were really expecting this especially
given the role she's taken on as the de
facto leader of belarus's opposition
from exile in the eu so i think that's
definitely also
as it were retribution for her
continued political work that really is
crucial to keeping those sanctions up
and to extending those sanctions against
the lukschenko regime in belarus we see
the picture is very different basically
all opposition activity is left the
streets people are if they're at all
organizing they're working from home
online social media but even that is
becoming increasingly dangerous people
are being sent to jail for increasing
terms just for sending links in private
messages to
independent media that are deemed to be
extremists so the regime in no mood to
compromise no mood to suggest any kind
of openness with its opponents and a
situation where
any kind of open defiance gets you in
jail for a very long time tw
correspondent nick connolly reporting
for us from kiev thanks so much for the
update
you